I am Matt Wendling. I'm the Scoutmaster of Troop 333 in Avon, Ohio. This edition of the Scoutmaster
podcast is sponsored by backers like me. Thank you, Clark. And now to you, Scoutmaster.
Here's an interesting question, Aponder, If a scouter is alone in the forest
and there are no scouts around and he gives a direction, will he still be ignored?
Think about that one. I think it's probably true. Hey, this is podcast number 323.. Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. It's summertime and everybody's
off to scout camp, so there's not a lot to share in the mailbag. I wrote a post this past week-
that's on Facebook and it's also at scoutmastercgcom- called Authentic Scouting is viral and there's
been some very positive response to that, so make sure to check that out when you get a chance
To do a little housekeeping for the podcast. this podcast number 323 is being published on July 11th.
I'll have podcast 324 next week, on July 18th, and then the podcast takes a break. That way
I get to go to summer camp and then we have a canoeing trip up in Algonquin Provincial Park in
Ontario, Canada, and the podcast will return, hopefully with wonderful stories about all of those
adventures, on August 22nd, And during that time. I'll post some favorite editions of the podcast
from the archive. This past week was a holiday week with July 4th, but I did manage to have one
live chat session. These normally happen Tuesday and Wednesday mornings. Keep an eye on our
Facebook feed and our Twitter feed for an announcement that we'll be on with a live chat.
Lots of people check in And this week Ed Wilcock, who's in Colleen and Fort Hood, Texas,
who's a Weeblos 2 den leader for PAC 248, checked in, and so did Richard Willimus,
who is with the Notwood 186 Cub PAC in Edmonton, Alberta, Canada, And Richard's the section
leader there. So Ed and Richard checked in for the first time on the live chat this week.
Lots of frequent flyers show up. Sometimes we talk about real important stuff and sometimes we just
talk. So let me ask a favor of you this week. If you're a regular reader and listener and the
resources we've created have helped you, I want to take a moment and ask you to return the favor.
You can support the work that we do financially by making a one-time payment
and becoming a ScoutmasterCGcom backer, or you can make a subscription payment via Patreon-
PATREON- by pledging $5 or more a month. There are special premiums available to anyone who becomes
a patron or a backer. So go to ScoutmasterCGcom, look right up there at the right-hand side of
the top of the page, and you'll see links about how to become a backer and how to become a
patron, And those same links are in the podcast notes. And I want to take a moment to personally
thank Matt Wendling and Larry Gonzalez, who've become backers since our last podcast, And I want
to thank Robert Williams and Joshua Starr, who've become patrons since our last podcast. So take
a little time this week, figure out what works for you and I'll be sure to thank you personally
on next week's podcast. I'm going to take up the remainder of the podcast, talking about an
event I attended this past Saturday, some of the people I went with and talked with there,
and just some things in general. I think it's timely because it's all about scout camp And that's
going to be the entirety of this week's podcast. It's July, We're going to take it easy, So let's
get started, shall we?
If you're a regular listener to the podcast, you've heard me talk about our summer camp. I'm in
Chester County Council, which is in the southeast corner of the state of Pennsylvania,
and our scout reservation- the horseshoe scout reservation has two camps, camp horseshoe
and camp where, and it straddles the Mason-Dixon line down in the very southeast corner of the
state of Pennsylvania and the very northeast corner of the state of Maryland. Our property
is in three counties, five townships in two states and it is on a piece of property where
the Octoraro Creek kind of turns back on itself and thus it got its name: camp horseshoe.
This past Saturday we had the horseshoe scout reservation alumni association gathering,
which is an annual event where anybody who's spent at least one night in either camp
horseshoe or camp where can join the alumni association. you can come
and the alumni association does projects for the camp. but mostly the alumni association
is a point of contact for people who consider that particular camp to be a very special place,
and I'm going to play a couple of recordings of people that I talked to. Let me begin by playing
a recording of a couple of guys just kind of recalling the first time they came to
camp back in the 1970s and I got to serve on staff with both of these guys, Bob Matchy
and Mark Hammond, and- and you'll hear Bob speak first, It was 1978, and I was a brand new scout,
I just joined in March of that year and it was the first time I was home away from home
for about for two weeks. the extended time period and camp has changed a lot since then.
1980, I became a CIT. I actually worked in- I don't know, I'm sorry- 1979. I was a very young CIT
in second year because I had such a good time the year before I worked. then I came two weeks
to camp, did the CIT in the second half of the season and 1980, I became a counselor
and worked in camp craft for a number of years and then I spent a stint in the kitchen
when some help was needed there and I think, all told, I've been nine years on the staff.
I was a first as a camper here in summer camp in 79..
1982, I took Wilder Survival Merit Badge from Bob Matchy, came on staff in 83 as a CIT and I started
as the program CIT working for John Kemmerer. I went to the rifle range and then to handicraft
and then to headquarters and then to the kitchen for a couple years and then program
director and then assistant camp director. I remember when I was 16 years old talking
to my friends about: you know, you're going to go live in the woods for the summer and work for
$275 for eight weeks. You know what are you not? And I said what are you doing? You know
we're making ice cream cones at Dairy Queen. and I said I'm running a shotgun range
and I'm teaching kids how to shoot guns and I'm not living with my parents.
End of story. You know you learn so much about what you're capable of doing
and you know you really had opportunities working at camp staff that as a teenager
you didn't have anywhere else in life. Yeah, certainly the leadership aspect of it,
the personal responsibility and I think the scouting movement in general has helped me out
in so many ways, you know. but certainly working down at Horseshoe and the enthusiasm, the can-do
attitude is something that you just can't compare to anywhere else. The other person I
wanted you to hear from is a name that is familiar to generations of campers at Camp Horseshoe
and he's a pretty special guy in scouting- to our former camp director, Ernie Heegard,
and Ernie shared of his history with the camp with me. So 1946, first year, yeah, and you just
grabbed some of your buddies and went to the council office on High Street opposite the
Warner Theater and that's where you would register for camp and you picked a camping
period, either first two weeks, second two weeks or third two weeks, or, if you were so inclined,
you could come for the whole summer. And so how many years is a camp that you figured?
Total years here is 71.. I joined the staff rather quickly. I think the first year
was a camper. the next year part of it was a camper and the rest of it was an
assistant stockade leader. Then I washed dishes for a summer. That was the way you got a job.
You know. if you couldn't last through that they didn't invite you back.
And then the next joined the aquatics department and I was the boating director.
Just before my 26th birthday I was asked to go into the military
in the County Intelligence Corps so that I could use leave time to spend time here
the next couple of years, And it was soon after that I guess I was camp director 29 years.
I did have a short term over at what is now camp aware. It was the explorer base
and I did that for a couple of years. Those are a few snapshots that I'm sure
if you've hung around scouts long enough, you've been to summer camp, maybe you've been
involved with your scout camp. maybe you've been on a camp staff. These are snapshots that I'm sure
evoke familiar connections and familiar feeling As I was down there this past weekend
and talking with people. we were talking about names and places and camp traditions and old
stories that you know are meaningful to us because, well, we we've lived through them
and we know all these people. But I was thinking about the broader implications of what a place
like Camp Horseshoe means. because if you've hung around scouting for long enough and you've
gone to summer camp and everything like that, there's probably a place like Camp Horseshoe
that bears that same kind of meaning for you. And I just remember the first few times I went
down to Camp Horseshoe as a Weevillows den leader in the early 1980s and then as a scout master
and then as a staff member, And I think of the drive down that gravelly rutted camp road and
pulling into central camp and just kind of knowing that all was going to be right with the world.
You know that feeling. And one of my absolute favorite spots at our camp
is an area that we call the athletic field. It's down along the creek, It's a big grassy flood plain
and you can stand there right at the creek, right at the swinging bridge that we call the OA bridge
because it leads over to another part of camp where the OA fire circle is, And look up the hill
at camp and you might be able to spot one or two of the buildings. When camp is in session
during the summer, you can certainly hear voices, and but if you imagine this with me,
you're kind of at the lowest geographical point of the camp and it stretches up the hill in front of
you. in that field and in the forest that surrounds you there is every possible shade of green And
if you go down there just as the sun's going down late of a summer evening or early in the
morning, just as the sun is coming up, you're very likely to spot some deer or some wild turkeys,
And I could go on and on. I could describe it to you. but there's a place like that
for you too, right? I mean, there's some place where you can kind of sit back and you can take
it all in And, like I said, all feels right with the world. So my whole point in sharing with you
wasn't to talk about the particular history of a certain camp or the particular names
that are associated with a certain camp, because I'll tell you something, okay, While I'm sure
we would all defend how wonderful our own scout camp is and how unique and how it's the best in
the country, All of that really isn't as important as the connection that you have
to scouting through that place, The kind of things that it gave you when you were a
youngster, the kind of meaning that it held for you, And now that you're a little bit older,
or maybe a lot older like me- the way that you can introduce that wonderful place,
that state of mind and heart, to young people. Here's my point, if there is a point to all this.
These places are a privilege, an opportunity and an obligation. We're tremendously privileged to
stand on the shoulders of many, many people who helped establish these places and all of
the resources and traditions associated with them, And we have the wonderful opportunity to be able to
enjoy them and to lend our effort to the creation and maintenance of those resources. And we have
the obligation to make sure that we share them with as many young people as possible.
There's this wonderful, mysterious alchemy that happens when we get to spend some time
at Scout Camp. Maybe it's just short of a week, or a whole week or a couple of weeks that you get to
do that of a summer and you get to bring your scouts there. But what important work, what great fun
and what a great, good place to go. I hope you enjoy your time at Scout Camp this summer.
Get in touch and let me know how it went And I'll tell you how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks for listening to this 223rd edition of the Scout Master Podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch- Pretty easy. You'll find 1600 plus articles and
over 300 editions of the podcast at scoutmastercgcom. And, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates by email. You can join us in the vast panorama of social
media outlets. There are 14,000 folks who like Scout Master blog on Facebook. We have a course
of tweeters on Twitter and we proffer pultritudinous pictures publicly with a
parcel of prolific pinners on Pinterest. You can watch us at Scout Master CG on YouTube.
but if you can't face Facebook and Twitter, it makes you bitter. If you have no interest in
Pinterest, that's okay, Bunky, zoom in to the late 1990s and fire off a good old-fashioned email.
I'm always available at Clark at scoutmastercgcom. That's C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
And if none of that works for you. the next time you're down at your Scout Reservation,
get up on the roof of the headquarters building, because you will find there a special spotlight
that has been installed in camp headquarters buildings all across the United States with
a secret signal. Shine that up against the clouds one evening and I will be sure to get in
touch to answer your questions. By now it should be rather abundantly clear that the Scout Master
blog and the Scout Master podcast are not official publications of anyone other than myself.
I'm not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America or any Scouting Organization for that
matter. It's just me talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand to my fellow Scouters
and perhaps have a little bit of fun along the way. And speaking of fun, here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir. Until next time, everyone.